é
sont renforcées sur l'eau
comme dans les airs.
L'arrivée du président américain
à l'ONU ne passe jamais
inaperçue. Mais avec le nouveau
tournant que prend la guerre
en Ukraine...
avec cette menace nucléaire
à peine voilée
de Vladimir Poutine...
et l'annonce d'une mobilisation
de milliervistes
russes sur le front ukrainien...
les attentes à l'égard
de Joe Biden et de son discours
étaient encore plus grandes.
Il a dénoncé une guerre décidée
par un seul homme, visant
tir le droit d'exister
de l'Ukraine, déterminé
à l'effacer de la carte.
La Russie doit en subir
les conséquences, sans quoi
les principes défendus par l'ONU
seront, selon lui, tous menacés.
Mais face à cette guerre,
l'ONU révèle une fois de plus
ses limites. Selon Joe Biden,
les veto au conseil de sécurité
devraient être évités, le nombre
de membres permanents et non
permanents, augmenté. Un appel
à la réforme qui n'est pas
nouveau, mais le contexte
de la guerre en Ukraine
confirme sa nécessité, selon
le président de la Lettonie.
L'idée n'est pas simple
à mettre en oeuvre.
MARIE-JOËLLE ZAHAR, dir., Réseau
recherche sur opérations de atix
- Le problème, c'est que
ni les membres permanents ni,
par ailleurs, les membres
des Nations unies "at large",
donc les membres de l'assemblée
générale, ne sont
sur les critères, le nombre
et éventuellement les candidats
à la réfo... à l'accession
au conseil de sécurité.
- Une réforme qui ne se fera
donc pas du jour au lendemain.
Entre-temps, les leaders
utilisent les outils
diplomatiques à leur disposition
pour tenter de freiner
les visées de la Russie.
EMMANUEL MACRON,
président de la France
- C'est que tout le monde puisse
mettre maintenant le maximum
de pression sur le président
Poutine pour qu'il cesse cette
guerre qui n'a plus aucun sens.
e ou non, les leaders
choisissent encore le forum de
l'ONU pour envoyer des signaux
à la communauté internationale
et à l'opinion publique. Et même
s'il brillait par son absence,
ce n'est peut-être pas un hasard
si Vladimir Poutine a choisi de
faire sa déclaration belliqueuse
au moment de l'assemblée
générale annuelle.
Ici Madeleine Blais-Morin,
Radio-Canada, New